arriving in Tehran to push for
de-escalation facing haiku mas were
multiple entangled crises all centering
on Iran economic sanctions a nuclear
deal in disarray and rising tensions
with the u.s. his welcome by iran's
Foreign Minister Mohammad Javad Zarif
talks went over time afterwards Zarif
spoke repeatedly of war the new tension
in our region is a result of the
economic war the United States declared
against Iran the only way to decrease
tensions in the region is to stop the
economic war one cannot expect an
economic war to continue against the
Iranian people and that those waging
this war and those supporting it remain
safe must responded continuing the
references to war there is war in Syria
and in Yemen fortunately not here we
want to do everything we can to keep it
that way
nevertheless the tensions here in the
region are worrying what a contrast to
the optimism of 2015 when Iran agreed to
limit its nuclear ambitions in a
landmark deal in return international
sanctions on Iran would be lifted but
under President Donald Trump the u.s.
pulled out of the treaty and re imposed
sanctions which have been crippling
Iran's economy the US has also sent
warships to the Middle East part of a
pressure campaign that some fear risks
escalating into open conflict now asked
about rescuing what's left of the deal
Maas had this to offer
we won't work any miracles but we'll do
everything in our power to prevent
failure Iran has already said it will
resume enriching uranium if sanctions
are not eased by July 7th at that point
the nuclear deal would be all but
history off more on this story we're
joined by DW is very own a minor well
Shahs thanks for being with us this
morning
German Foreign Minister Heiko Maas he
went to Tehran hoping to salvage the
nuclear deal but did he have really
anything to all
the Iranians other than the encouraging
words well Germany is seen as a
strongest mediator between Iran and its
remaining partners in the deal in the
the EU partners and since 2015 Germany
had worked very hard along with friends
and Britain for Tehran to get the
promised economic benefits out of the
deal and so I would say this mood and
goodwill of the remai remaining from the
remaining partners of that deal France
Britain and Germany it's not just
optimism because it could also lead to a
further talks without the u.s. towards
eventually a new deal should the current
deal not survive the tensions and also
German Foreign Minister Heiko Maas
acknowledged that without the u.s. it
would be difficult to help Iran
economically but he still trying trying
well iran's Foreign Minister in that
press conference he warned that those
waging economic war against his country
could not expect to quote remain safe
what do you make of that statement well
it's not a threat we could say the US
has deployed its military in the Middle
East to increase the pressure on Tehran
and Teheran has responded by saying that
well if that's the road that the US want
to take well they're ready for it so
that goes on to show that Iran is very
clear about what he wants don't we gonna
make sanctions no pressure no military
pressure but the threat is there and
that could actually make the conflict
escalate quite quickly throughout the
Middle East and bring up an armed
confrontation that none of the European
partners of Iran want to see okay nobody
will particularly the Europeans perhaps
but others in the region as well nobody
really wants that a war to see a war
there but if the EU can't counterbalance
the impact of the sanctions from the US
on Iran
why is here an even talking to the well
German Foreign Minister Heiko Maas was
adamant that he really wanted to
de-escalate the tensions in the Persian
Gulf but for Iran it is important to
keep the talks going because of the
economic interests it has with the
European Union
because it showed good we'll ever since
2015 before Dan Ultron pulled out of the
agreement Iran had complied with the
prerequisites for the economics the
economic sanctions to be lifted at least
according to the UN Observatory
monitoring its nuclear activities so it
just wants to ensure that it will have
its economic interest defended Amanda
thank you so much TWA political
correspondent Amanda well Shas thank you